investors are bracing for more shocks
from Wall Street after very turbulent 24
hours this morning overseas markets from
Britain to Japan are down dramatically
Hong Kong's main stock index fell more
than 5% after yesterday's huge sell-off
on Wall Street Dow Jones Industrial
Average lost 1175 points that's the
biggest one-day point loss ever
and right now Dow futures are trending
lower again ahead of this morning's
opening bell bianna golodryga is here
with what's hurting stocks beyond a good
morning good morning Gail is a sea of
red on Wall Street yesterday in Monday
stock market dive rattled investors who
had been watching the markets hit record
highs this morning many are asking if
things are looking up on Main Street
why is Wall Street seemingly so panicked
Monday's opening bell brought a
rollercoaster day on Wall Street at one
point the Dow plunged as much as 1,600
points the biggest midday loss and the
indexes history by closing it was down
1175 points enough to wipe out all
gained since the start of 2018 we're
doing fantastically the stock market hit
another note all-time high the president
regularly takes credit for the market
success the Dow has risen around 8,000
points since he took office but in
response to yesterday's sell-off the
White House said in a statement the
president's focus is on our long-term
economic fundamentals which remain
exceptionally strong the economy is
still booming some experts agree Joe
salucci is a partner at famous trading
the unemployment numbers are going lower
so the fundamentals which is what
markets are built on they're still there
but a correction was needed to kind of
get the excesses off unemployment has
fallen to a 17-year low but wages have
remained stagnant until January when
they rose by 2.9 percent
former chair of the Federal Reserve
Janet Yellen was asked on CBS Sunday
morning whether stocks were artificially
high I don't want to say too high but I
do want to say high price earnings
ratios are near the high end of their
historical ranges if you're looking and
what the Fed does next is a main fact
behind the markets nosedive higher wages
lead to fears of inflation many now
believe the Federal Reserve under its
new chairman Jerome Powell will begin
raising interest rates leading Wall
Street to worry that the days of easy
money may be coming to an end John
bianna thanks